all right please please please talk in
your mouth I'm talking to your
microphone I was just saying that like
perspectives you were saying the other
week that it was okay to be a cyber and
be okay in that position yeah isn't she
married or in a relationship
I'm not trying to wipe it but then
doesn't that devalue you as a man no I
mean
sorry sorry so so
I mean that would be nice but no I mean
women don't give a [ __ ]
yeah yeah do you think how many times is
Drake stolen people's girls it's our
women oh no I'm not sleeping with Drake
well that's kind of danger trading on
that little line of old girls and hoes
the same way they're all men are trash
that's not really the case and I
actually I
no I'm not saying that you said I'm just
saying this comparatively the same thing
where he's just coming out of your mouth
the same way that I could say oh man a
trash so you shouldn't really say it
like that is generalized when you keep
talking about girls don't care girls do
care and not every single girl I'm
saying by and large girls do not care if
men but they do what you're seeing what
don't what you're seeing what what the
world is actually actually showing you
and what a lot of men actually suffer
with is the fact that they are dealing
with hoes and they think every woman is
a hoe and not every woman is a hoe
actually at the percentage of a lot of
women that are hosts maybe I should
quite small because a lot of women have
very high standards so they're not even
wanting to do that you never I'm not
saying all women are hoes I've never
said that wait wait I I it's not even by
large either wait wait I'm not saying
all women are hoes I've never said that
you can't catch me on a podcast saying
all women are hot but I'm saying is that
by and large women don't care and the
reason the reason if they did so many
women that come on the show it wouldn't
be such a large percentage that have
picked men that cheat on them
and like women like women like men that
other women want to bang and there's
times
and there's and there's bile yeah yeah
I'll give you I'll give you an example
pickup artist teach men to wear rings so
they can get more girls
because women see that as a sign of
pre-selection oh if he married her he'd
marry me and women and and throughout
history men that could get multiple
women it was a sign that they could take
care of those women
so it's like so I'm not saying every
single woman you know some some women
have dads to like you know tell them
don't go there whatever whatever but but
I'm saying by and large women don't care
that's why they have it by and large by
and large even me like if a guy said oh
I slept with a married chick like am I
gonna care like it wasn't me
the girls do not like men that do not
attract girls I'm telling you this
little fat guys guys aren't you falling
for that trap where you're generalizing
in a way that doesn't serve you so
clearly clearly clearly you want the
woman that does actually care whether a
dude cheats on her
yeah and that's what I'm saying you know
so clearly that's what you'd be looking
for right so clearly clearly that makes
everyone's life easier right so if
you're saying oh most women don't like
this but most women like
um Men Who cheat on them and Etc then
surely we don't want the ones that no I
said I said most women don't care if you
slept with a married guy but I think I
think
I made the point of handles being the
side dude and because it is the last one
he had said and so it was kind of like
in my mind I was like he's not like
marrying up in what he's saying in that
moment so what she was saying is that
like as a woman if I met handles and he
was like yeah I used to date a married
woman would I care if I want him and I
feel that he adds value to my life I
wouldn't if anything else yeah and I'm
saying like by a large woman don't care
maybe we should
I'm not saying it's like the right thing
but like if I'm being honest with you if
you think he's handsome he's got a good
job he has all the things you look for
but he dated a married woman at one
point
um
you made a married woman step outside
the top woman I meet like the the a plus
woman
again intelligence is my biggest thing
they they'll she'll she'll cut you out
if you like talk the wrong way she'll be
like this guy's a [ __ ] boy and I'm like
I did barely said because you started
Alex but I just think it's because
you're not that guy to her no no
and that's that's fine but I'm saying
wait no I said to her I didn't say to
anyone but I'm saying like a lot of
times like when girls cut you out for
stupid reasons it's just because they
don't like you because the same girl
that's like because we again most girls
talk like we talk to these girls behind
the scenes you see how they move and
they'll be like oh I won't accept that
that and that and they won't from the
guy they don't like but if they like a
guy
some dudes get an application at the
front door and some dudes get let in the
back entrance yeah I get I don't have to
pay nothing it's just like the clubs if
some dudes gotta line up and go through
the process and some dudes just get the
gate open one time but I think I think
you're still you're still like targeting
your the way you think about this for
the woman you don't want in it I I think
about the women's it's not that girl was
married to the next guy and actually
went back to the guy who she used to
date at Uni she's off the market French
royalty do you want to smile like she
she I didn't say anything like she could
she could already kind of tell that like
I wasn't ready at the time bro so I
would say no I don't really agree with
what you're saying you're talking about
women on the streets no I'm talking
about women in general bro in just in
just a generalized situation like you
have to come to a level of agreement
with yourself as a dude where you go
like you know what I'm just gonna work
on me because there is nothing out here
in this world that can guarantee me or
give me any security about where a
woman's been unless I bump into buck
into her while I'm in my teens young
like these guys right so once I've
reached a certain age you just kind of
have to accept regardless of whoever I
pick they're going to have a past
regardless now me as a what they like to
call high value man what I like to call
the difference is
I get to choose now I can choose and be
like do I accept your past
or do I judge you by your past based on
your current actions because every woman
and just like every man can be taught we
can all learn things we can all change
our habits and practice different ways
of applying ourselves do you see me
that's why you see do that will be a
gangster on a road and come home
religious it's the same thing with women
they can be in that stage until they
really take steps to get themselves out
of that stage and as soon as they're out
of that stage it's like an Unwritten
kind of broadcast that goes out where
it's like oh she's wiped up man I ain't
even gonna holler at no more even though
you might have hollered at her like a
whole back in the day but you can see
from your side man like you were saying
perspective oh she's taking her [ __ ]
serious good luck to you wish you the
best shout me when you're out of it like
that's the reality of it I'm just saying
I feel like people
people once you kind of hear this
rhetoric all the time where you
generalize based on the common you know
the average more than women which which
you probably don't want to have a
long-term relationship with I feel like
you start to see that all the time and I
think there's there's a lot more women
out here who are intelligent and who do
value their Chastity in in a way that's
sufficient for you know whatever
standard you may have but they're not
hot but I think not that they they just
have to notice bro I just think I think
most men don't have that high of
Standards
I think this is like kind of a crazy
argument because men really don't ask
for much
I don't even know a single guy that's
saying oh oh like maybe one out of the
months I've done the show that said five
bodies is too many maybe one like most
guys they say they want they wait they
say 10 they say 10 but they mean 15 to
20 because like when I press them a
little bit if I say oh 20 but really hot
with good chemistry they're like ah I
let it go
you've got to be wary of of generalizing
people or women based on the women you
don't want because I I found them in my
in my life that
the more I see this in people and I've
realized in a lot of cases they won't
actually like that because I was
thinking about you know all this kind of
rhetoric I judge them very quickly and
later realized oh [ __ ] yeah but it's a
pointless point is I'm not debating
anyone I just I think the point is like
even if you get married it's still 50 50
so you could say half aren't what
happened
half are gonna leave here
but I'm not disagreeing with anyone else
like what what it sounds like to me like
I'm trying to decipher what you're
saying is that you should just give hoes
a chance that's like that's how it's
coming across no no I think I think we
should be with bro like we there's no
ugly hoes
I've heard guys say like the fours and
the threes because because they're just
like so happy to be there
for the attention
you don't even have to take her out to
dinner
as well you don't you just tell them
the girls you're talking about are the
bin like what we call paper bags plastic
Bagels where you put the bag on their
head that's what you're talking about
they're not hoes what are they them
they're not hoes let me tell you why
they're hooked they're not hoes yeah
because they don't have the ability to
sell themselves to the entire Market
they're like the men they're like the
bottom of the barrel
managers
they're the bottom they're the bottom of
the barrel men who take what they can
just like how we know men have sex with
who they can and women have sex with who
they want you all know a bunch of women
security listen there's a lot of girls
that you know that ain't pretty that
ain't the prettier the bunch but will
sleep with anyone and take whatever
attention they can get this is still a
hoe just because she's not in the top
thing of beauty it doesn't mean she's
not right
so generally like Okay so
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible